I get to watch a boat unloading its
month's catch hola
how are you $2 a kilo for the meat
versus $28 a kilo for the fins there's
no doubt with these fishermen are
interested
so rather fins just the fins
soon after Finn after finish up in
that's the prize fin there that one
there that's where the money is the tail
the most tender parts and the part
that's most sought-after in China I know
this is legal but I find the sheer
quantity of sharks being landed
distressing this is all for that one
dish that shark fin soup it's honestly
why now starting to make me feel [ __ ]
sick it's relentless
and now I'm about to witness firsthand
how these shots are being caught
I can't believe we go on this photo that
my journey has taken me ten thousand
miles from Taiwan to the other side of
the world and this tiny boat fishing to
me Asia's huge demand for fins we get on
that thing that's not a bonus of after I
know [ __ ]
okay
I'm joining a crew of four ten days into
the month out at sea let's go again okay
this is a small boat for the 12 mile
long line with a youngin hopes on there
shark shark yeah first shark and it's a
baby silkie one of the most over fish
species in the world
like most sharks they give birth to very
few pups once every two years less than
a year old these sharks are being killed
before given a chance to reproduce
it's not the quick humane death I'm used
to seeing with animals back home it's
hard to watch
I've never been exposed the reality of
longline fishing [ __ ] it's
indiscriminate turtle [ __ ] out it's
turning out to be a [ __ ] nightmare
after the turtle it's a succession of
baby silkies
then I'll make a startling discovery
what bait is that no Kudo
it's like yes I get can I have a shark
that's great showing for Sean so the
sharpest right as well what kind of what
kind of shark was that as bait pressure
pressure pressure shock
I'm a guess worse it's tragic that the
body of a thresher shark is of such
little value they're using it as bait
finished
the end of the line
[ __ ] for that